[Music]
it's funny so here's a question i meant
to ask you because we were talking about
this yesterday when you were talking to
the cops right
and when you when you were talking to
the cops
i
i'm a big i'm one of those big people
that's like i don't like i don't like
just [ __ ] like thin blue line all
cops are heroes like because i think
that's a problem but i'm also not one of
those people like [ __ ] all cops either
i'm one of those like depending on the
situation you know some cops could be
good some cops some cops will fight or
take your guns you know blindly throw my
support behind any group like university
but so you were talking to them now
what do you think
do you think that they believed on what
was going on inside or you think they
just wanted their pension to do their
job and look they told me to come here
dude it's just juvaldi i mean you know
their chief whatever their police chief
says they're gonna stand down you know
and so like they didn't have any
sergeant telling them what to do so they
just didn't want to go and shut it down
and in in you know case it was some sort
of homophobic thing you know what i mean
they didn't want to freaking even risk
being judged trying to shut it down but
yeah the thin blue line all that stuff i
love uh i love how people like
cheerleading the cops and when the cops
will close your business down close your
church down the cops are not i mean
they're not our friend unless they give
you a pass on a speeding ticket or some
crap but that's right yeah the cops
didn't the cops didn't run into the
school but they did run into that
[ __ ] bar that tried to open the cove
had locked down remember that but we
played that on the show they had like a
[ __ ] swat the [ __ ] local police
had a swat out there going to stop a bar
because he was like i'm not going to
shut down i need to make money but so so
yeah i know you you're right and i think
a lot of people like i always say this
it's like a lot of people i think we got
kind of fooled right when you think of
like after 2001
after 9 11 right everyone was like you
know so scared and that's how the
patriot act gets passed and every and
everyone's you know off uh i'll terrify
you know whatever whatever just just
just keep us safe to just keep us safe
and everyone's like thin blue line all
cops are heroes and you know those men
went out there to die and and the
military and oh man dude we used to the
conservatives used to simp for
corporations all the time
a lot of this is something that people
don't want to admit a lot of that's our
fault like a lot of the reason these
these corporations are [ __ ]
now because we thought they were going
to be our friends but they weren't our
friends they're their friends whoever's
the [ __ ] in power and now they're the
ones that are kicking you off kicking
you off getting you fired apologizing
they all have pride flags now and all
this and now they're trying to end your
life and it's the same thing with the
cops it's like thin blue line we support
you okay there's a shooting going to
school oh no we don't we're not gonna go
in there there's somebody shooting
you're a cop
yeah the only way we're gonna storm that
school is if that [ __ ] unarmed mother
goes into that school to get her kids
yeah they would have stormed the school
if there was a january 6 protester in
there
yeah and speaking of january 6 i mean we
can't say much about that but i mean
everybody's complaining that fox news
isn't covering it i mean literally these
people that are championing like the
police that they're the fbi these
alphabet agencies organized against our
own people i mean there's no need for
the cia it's ridiculous the cia there's
no need for a lot of three-letter
agencies in my [ __ ] opinion you know
oh i'm sorry well if we don't have the
three-letter agencies then who's gonna
murder all these children and set them
on fire oh that's a really good point
are you gonna do it but hey alex are you
gonna do it oh you're right then i guess
you know we need some of these agencies
right but that's why i like the heroes i
laugh when i see people like you know
hannity wearing a cia pin and an fbi pin
going like these these agencies i'm like
then take the pin off bud you know i
don't want to hear it
dude and they all sent for those things
they
okay he wants to wear the pen i mean
we're screwed when we actually put those
people in charge but dude you all
remember it wasn't that long ago we'll
occupy wall street all these liberal
freaks were against were
anti-establishment and now they're all
like oh i love the establishment 80 more
billion dollars to ukraine please yeah
no dude it's so it's so [ __ ]
hilarious and it's the same thing we
always talk about it but it's like
because you just got kicked off of
twitter and it's like
now all the [ __ ] lefties turn into
ron paul the moment you go man you know
kicking off people off the twitter takes
your free speech away like it's a
private company man they could do what
they want i'm like also now so now mr
occupy wall street they're a [ __ ]
they're a private company you can do
whatever they want wait hang on hang on
elon musk might buy twitter i'm suddenly
not okay with a private company now yeah
controlling the wait a minute i